hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
video game villains are designed to be
hated and despised for their outrageous
beliefs and evil deeds it keeps us going
until the bitter end to see the main
body get their comeuppance sometimes in
a few fleeting moments these dastardly
criminals actually have a point which
turns the tables on how we see
everything with that in mind here's six
videogame bad guys who were right all
along if you can get past all the
murdering and torturing they thing to do
by the way as anybody else notice how
many evil masterminds in film TV or
video games come British accents I've
never trusted the British with their
sexy damn voices anywhere home getting
sidetracked
prepare for spoilers for the following
[Music]
Assassin's Creed has taught us one way
of thinking assassin good Templar bad
much suddenly along comes Hayden Kenway
who are you Haytham Kenway natural
service who explains how a few
guidelines of coffin tables are what
society needs to prosper and evolve what
is it Templars truly seek order purpose
directly no more than that it's your lot
that means you can stand with it's
nonsense talk of freedom time was the
Suttons professed a far more sensible
goal
but peace freedom is peace oh no it's an
invitation to chaos we get to play as a
big dog share them in assassin's creed 3
for long enough to see here the
viewpoint and just as we're switching
our perspective on life it's ripped from
us by a characterless puppet whose name
sounds like a lyric from the Macarena
my name is Roger hangers on all right
well I'm not even going to try and
pronounce that let's let's just call in
Connor all right
okay so Haytham Kenway did kill a few
people along the way but you have to
commit to be successful bugarach Connor
nobody likes you pagan min evil dictator
sorry couldn't donut well maybe but look
at the situation you're putting during
the events of bash right for after civil
wars pretty much run the country into
the ground pagan has risen up
overthrowing the corrupt royal and
placing himself in charge as he tries to
improve the life of everyone he's up
against the resistance when you arrive
who are only here to replace the
dictator for their own nefarious means I
mean they call themselves the Golden
Path could that sound more elitist in
fact when the game is completed you
realize the country either becomes a
drug den for criminals or a
fundamentalist regime so things couldn't
be much worse with mini charge the first
time you meet the so called bud guy you
are fed a lavish meal and asked politely
to wait while he takes care of a quick
business meeting please state right here
enjoy the crab rangoon don't move I will
be right back come on now bad guys just
don't have manners like that unless
they're British of course you quickly
realize that vagin min he's not such a
bad guy stick around and he'll take care
of you
he'll first take you to your family's
burial site to put your mother's ashes
to rest and even attempts to act like a
father figure for you and installed you
as the next of kin and heir to the
country off standing in
don't worry about a thing my boy this is
soon be behind us we'll be off on that
land adventure because I have cleared my
calendar seems like a pretty cool dude
to me and he also wears purple Zeus what
is not to love let's forget how much he
likes torturing people as it's a bit of
a turn-on
those [ __ ] terrorists he ruined
everything
like dinner there's kind of screaming
bandits
gonna die left and right way handsome
jack is a name that truly inspires
confidence in Borderlands 2 Jack has
risen to the top of the hierarchy with
his no-nonsense treatment of bandits and
vicious gangs and his desire to improve
Pandora for all its inhabitants in a
nutshell handsome Jack wants to purge
this world of those treacherous gangs
and outlaws ultimately allowing the
world to be repopulated by lovely people
like you and dying
alright so it's a little bit like mass
genocide but at least his hearted in the
right place kill let's not mention his
enslaved daughter and the massive
flaming dragon thing he plumbs to purge
pandora with oh and he does kill a few
fun favorites along the way too I'm
going to check but what a guy in the
pre-sequel a large portion of the game
is based around how great Jack really is
I blame Hyperion cooperation for his
slight maniacal tendencies but I can
forgive him for that take the greatest
Jedi Knight strip away the force and
what remains they rely on it depend on
it more than they know Star Wars Knights
of the Old Republic too was the first
game which made me stop and appreciate
how complex the so-called villain could
be crea looks like a lovely granny who
was a badass at cooking and like the
stuck on the odd word as original but in
fact she has an on-off relationship with
the far
okay I can't sugarcoat it she durst it
well sort of us it look I said it was
complicated alright preah Ord Astraea if
you prefer what to rid the universe of
the force because she believes it
manipulates both the light and the dark
sides both the Jedi and the severe force
has a will it has a destiny for us all I
wield it but it uses us all and that is
abhorrent to me
I hate that it seems to have a will that
it would control us to achieve some
measure of balance when countless lives
are lost basically she wants to end the
Star Wars and bring about peace without
the pesky force trying to force people
to pick a side he definitely got a point
too but uses her manipulative powers to
coerce your character into certain
actions you are not a Jedi not truly and
it is for that that I love you I can
forgive her for that a friendly thing -
peer pressure never hurt anyone
he leave toward me
I see fingers digging into my head there
was nothing to show description'
infamously centered around the ultra
evil bastard Kessler not that one no no
not that one either yeah that's the one
that's the one Kessler after the race
via nuke Empire City killing most of the
inhabitants but also giving your
character cold a few cool superpowers
eventually the city falls into a
depression and Anarchy rulz
taking whatever they change
[Applause]
Tesla comes across as a complete tool
throughout the infamous story killing
Cole's girlfriend and vaporizing anyone
who helps them guess that's gonna pay
for this I'm gonna find that sick
bastard and I'm gonna kill him but
here's the twist Kessler is coal mine my
brain works unable to extend Chester and
Hollywood
that he come back in time to mold me and
a savior he failed to be going so far as
to kill the woman he locked I loved so
that I will be tied down by emotion
Tesla traveled back in time to prepare
cold for a wealth ending event which he
wasn't strong enough to prevent himself
Tesla even happily laid down his life to
push Cole on to awesomeness and it
worked out perfectly when the Beast
comes to wreck the world Cole and his
ragtag bunch of mercenaries are ready
and prevent the world's destruction thus
fulfilling Tesla's plant up if he just
didn't kill our girlfriend it would make
this entry much easier to pass the blast
but let's forgive him because come on
there's plenty more fish in the sea
I'm so glad you came it's an honor
really
so much resin is cut what do you want
I'd like to propose an alliance I think
two of us could accomplish great things
together
I don't work with criminals you need to
turn yourself in Batman Arkham origins
has many superheroes and villains but
Anarchy stands out okay so Anarchy isn't
the greatest name for a friendly
superhero but let's give him a chance
imagine if you live in Gotham City the
amount of corruption exploitation
mistreatment and spandex you'd see on a
daily basis could push you over the edge
anarchy our Lonny to a superhero friend
wants to put this right and end the
dishonesty at key spots around the city
so here's where he went a tiny bit too
far and planted bombs at those
destinations he realizes that that was
one step too far and gives Batman the
tools he needs to rectify the situation
Aniki stands for a rebuilt gotham but
Batman ain't having any of that he's the
only law renard of this town needs let
me ask you something you ever wonder if
you're the reason the three so messed up
because I have a lot of my pad and I'm
starting to think we're right come to
think of it he really does make a good
point so they're sick video game
villains who have a point if you can get
past all the murder and torture and
genocide and blown up who else do you
think this is to be heard out and seen
for the revolutionary hero they really
are please let me know your thoughts in
the comments I imagine from PlayStation
granade it has been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]